to celebrate oval series 3 coming out on
disney plus and hulu on june 2nd i
thought i would test my knowledge
welcome to scitrak your sci-fi tv movie
channel
so i found a quiz on life daily not
something i've ever heard of before but
it seems like an interesting quiz i
haven't looked at the questions just yet
so
come on play along go to the description
now you'll see that there's a link to
the game and you can do along with me
so let's have a quick look let's hit
so avoid the p corner take the science
christian because the orville blah blah
blah let's go down through
read more
get rid of that
so act this orville quiz and get shunted
back to the right timeline whatever that
means so how many years in the future is
the orville set 300 400 450 or 500 years
it's 350 or 400 years
i'm going to go with 400 years there we
go done first question down oh it looks
like it doesn't tell you straight away
so i'll have to put it in and go back at
the end button fine the doral bioship is
set to collide with a star um about six
months when the us orville makes contact
what is the name of the star
do you know i actually remember that
it's j2837
oh my god i have to actually remember
something that's weird i never the other
the thing i loved about this episode was
and the orville was always sort of like
seth mcfarlane wanted to make a star
trek series they wouldn't let him so he
went ah i'll make the oval name and it
was always like a love letter to the
next generation this episode in
particular you take out the orville and
the orville crew and put in picard data
and that lot this is a tng episode all
over it's so so a tng episode
and the oval has been mentioned a few
times on family guy which seth mcfaulin
also created meanwhile macronus simpsons
has also been mentioned on the show true
or false
true
what is male on earth is rollable the
uss orville he is the captain come on
that's an easy one which species in the
orville has the manufacturing of
advanced technology as a private
industry i would say mostly weapons
the mocklands
which species in the orville is the
opposite despising war and conflict was
it those fellas
um it wasn't written so the humans love
a bit of war
we're just like come on
bring it especially the british where we
go we went all over the world we
basically made an industry for like 500
years and definitely not lachlan's i
think that's the xenians
according to ed mercer during the
orville how many vessels make up the
planetary union space fleet
it's not four or five thousand it's two
or three thousand
i'm going three thousand that's a little
bit of a guess which actress played the
role of a lara catan in the orville i
know that i wanted to sage holston sage
there we go
what is the lara catan's role aboard the
us orville uss orville
chief of security
who says the following i feel as if i've
been standing my entire life and i've
just sat down
that was clyde and when he
developed a nicotine habit
what is the name of claire finn's sons
in the orville adam marcus adam and ty
marcus and ty simon and ty 100 thai
i know it's thai
i'm going marcus and ty i think
i can't grow facial hair right well
obviously i can but not very good and i
can't grow mustachio and i really want
to grow a bead when i can't
so jealous of this mustache this proper
tom selleck jobby can't grow one but
anyway bortis is a crew member onboard
the orville what is his home planet
called
markless sounds like um
a hot chocolate drink trying to see your
hot dogs
yeah sounds nice let's do that some
sprinkles lovely
um what day did the series 2 premiere of
the orville aired on fox
how the bloody hell would i know
that's the stupidest question
before or after christmas
toss a coin
we'll go after
that's a complete guess i have no clue
scott grimes and adrian piliki are
couple that is false even though they do
get photographed together a lot
who says the following cliches become
cliched precisely because they're valid
enough to bear endless repetition
um i'm gonna go it's not sort of finn
would say
oh no sorry that's what isaac would say
it's not so i can't see ed saying that i
don't remember saying that anymore
admiral pereira doctor finn
i'm gonna go with dr finn medicine woman
there we go go to that one but that
might be a little bit of a guess as well
which remember the earth is all veil is
from planet azalea uh where is the name
tala ke ali that's her
what is the name of the species which is
the main antagonist of the u.n is the
clear
and from now on that's if ever i do an
orville video it's going to be
the clear
a special fuel source is used when
character door will need to travel
faster than light uh what is the name of
this fuel source delithium star trek
hanky dyssonium hmm unobtainium
sank and on a pentium it's dystonia
who says the following on behalf of the
planetary union and welcome to the
galaxy
it's hared
will you be watching the orville series
three nights [ __ ]
yes i will of course i will
easy cigarette camera
flipping eck
oh mommy
i got 20 out of 20.
so that means i don't actually have to
go through and tell the answers is it
because i just told you the answers as i
was going through oh my god i'm good but
let's just double check
i don't want to gloat here but i mean i
never get 20 out of 20 on these quizzes
400 years
j2837 that was that was weirdly i
remembered that i don't know why
uh knew that one knew that one
knew that one to be fair i did have a
couple of guesses i didn't know so
i'm accepting that as a moral victory 20
out of 20. i know my orville
so um none of you guys out there can
beat me but please give it a try see if
you can at least match me
because i got 20 out of 20.
so
let's see what happens on that one so
please guys get into the comments tell
me what you think and are you looking
forward to series three of the orville
because i tell you what looking at the
advent they've really upped the budget
for the series it's looking really good
i'm like you know they're calling it
orville new horizons they're
acknowledging that it's been a big gap
between series two and series three
coming out you know and they're trying
to build up a bit of excitement it's not
just series three it's something even
better new horizons it's like a whole
new series
this is a series as well that for me
i could i said seth mcfarlane was not
allowed to make a star trek series so he
created his own it was very much a love
letter to the next generation
but i think it's become more than that
and it's become more than a silly comedy
like a lot of his other projects there
is still elements of humor but really
the comedy for series two toned down
quite a lot i mean it was it was it was
screwball comedy in the first series
like i said toned down a lot for the
second and it looks like the third
series is going to have elements of
humor again we can see in the trailer
already but
you know it's really is toning up the
action and yeah the space battles which
is a sci-fi fan god i love space battles
but like i said get in the comments tell
me exactly what you think are you
looking forward to this and what are you
hoping to see in series three of the
orville if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification it really helps us out also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button
that really would be amazing
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you